[Musique]
david zobda bonjour bonjour avez vous
êtes le secrétaire général de bâtir le
pays martinique membres de l'alliance
entre une martinique nouvelle et votre
parti présente une candidate joseph
manno législatives dans le centre
l'atlantique c'est bien ça c'est bien ça
alors c'est quand trois candidats sur
toute la martinique qui donc 15 dans la
circonscription centre l'atlantique
c'est un peu beaucoup
oui mais avant de répondre à votre
question je voudrais faire mise au point
je je m'élève peut fortement contre
l'absence de première lors de la
présentation de notre candidat dimanche
matin ni la radio ni télé okonedo
médiane était là et je m'élève fortement
contre ça parce que ça remet en cause le
principe fondamental de l'égalité totale
entre les candidats je termine entre
légalité traitement entre les candidats
et c'est un principe que nous attendons
de tous les médias et en particulier du
service public qui en la matière doit
faire preuve d'exemplarité
je suis là aussi pour ça je réponds
protection pour éviter toute polémique
polémique il n'a jamais elle n'a jamais
voulu boycotter compliqué et l'encens et
si vous êtes là c'est qu'on ne cherche
pas à boycotter c'est très bien d'autres
parties de hockey
je vois là parce qu'on n'a jamais
boycotté de quelques secondes paul
caution d'être en vie c'est sur notre
engin de ce terme
alors c'est 53 candidats membres vous
permettez moi de m'exprimer s'il vous
plaît suis venu pour ça
vous m'avez invité vos sapins oui mais
pas pour parler seul mais pour parler de
la campagne
oui mais je le fonds n'a pas beaucoup de
temps dit on à peine dix minutes laissez
moi parler on aurait dû la musique je
réaffirme l'absence est préjudiciable
maintenant je les dis sur la fia ont
fortement nous passons maintenant à
l'essentiel de notre discussion
vous m'avez posé la question sur le
nombre de candidats weekes candidat
c'est beaucoup quelles en sont les
raisons
je pense que c'est le principe
démocratique qui permet à chaque citoyen
de se présenter à une élection dès lors
qu'il a le sentiment qu'il peut apporter
quelque chose au débat public
mais c'est aussi lié certainement à
l'éclatement de la vie politique ici
ailleurs
et puis l'avènement de président qui
étend aux partis traditionnels
je pense que les martiniquais ont senti
qu'ils avaient là une opportunité à se
présenter à cette élection pourquoi pas
comment comptez-vous face à ce nombre
important de candidats vous comment
comptez vous vous démarquez écoutez il
ya beaucoup de candidats mais il y a
aussi des candidats majeurs
on le sait bien la vie politique
martiniquaise est ainsi fait que des
candidats majeurs sont portés par des
par des organisations politiques ou des
alliances qui représente quand même
quelque chose et qui ont déjà montré par
le passé ce qu'elles sont capables de
faire c'est le cas aussi pour notre
candidat josette manin qui fait preuve
d'une notoriété sur le terrain et d'une
expérience chacun reconnaît donc hélas
elle a pour elle à la fois la compétence
à la fois l'expérience à la fois la
disponibilité toute une série de qualité
que les lecteurs sera bien identifier et
reconnaître dans le nombre de luttes
dans le nombre de colis d'un possible
quels sont les enjeux pour pour votre
parti bâtir le pays martinique
on sait que seul parti ancré au lamentin
quels sont les enjeux pour pour vous les
enjeux sont très importants vous savez
les toutes les élections sont
importantes le reportage de tout à
l'heure où il a démontré qu'il y a un
intérêt financier pour chacun des partis
mais au-delà de ça il y à l'affirmation
de certain nombre d'idées que nous
portons le valeurs que nous défendons
mais surtout la place de bâtir le pays
martinique dans l'alliance ampoules map
nouvelle et puis là et plus
singulièrement sur le lamantin les
enjeux des législatives précède d'autres
enjeux qui sont les enjeux municipal
n'est simple pour les ministres
donc la stratégie politique est ainsi
faite que une élection succédé à une
autre on doit se positionner sur alors
justement venu pour les municipales de
2020 est ce que aujourd'hui si
l'élection à ne pas perdre parce que
cela pourrait vous
fragilisée en 2020 non je ne je ne
raisonne pas comme ça il est très clair
qu'on doit entretenir un dialogue
constant avec l'électorat notamment mai
mais en particulier avec les citoyens et
plus largement de la circonscription et
du lamentin et en particulier mais une
élection ne ressembla ne ressemble pas à
une autre élection municipale est
extrêmement particulière ici en
martinique
ce n'est pas parce qu'on perd une
élection que l'on va perdre la suivante
à titre d'exemple nous avions bien perdu
en 2012 l'élection législative et nous
avons brillamment gagné élections
municipales en 2014
donc vous voyez les effets ne sont pas
les mêmes les dynamiques ne sont pas
forcément les mêmes mais il y a un trait
commun
si celui du dialogue permanent que l'on
doit entretenir avec les citoyens alors
ce ne sont pas les mêmes élections ce
pas lui même candidat
mais les chiffres peuvent donner une
indication quant on prend l'élection les
élections à la 7e sur cette
circonscription centre l'atlantique
serge letchimy au premier tour est en
tête sur toutes les communes sauf au
lamentin il faudra vraiment batailler là
oui mais c'est spécifique vous savez ce
n'est pas très parlant d'élection la ctm
c'était vraiment particulier c'est la
première fois qu'on faisait une élection
de ce type de cette nature arrivé dans
la circonscription mais c'est moins
exigeant même l'américaine mais ça
s'explique c'est à lui même c'est pas
les mêmes candidats à cette femme voit
la passe au pied ils sont pas les même
dynamique
donc il faut il faut bien apprécier les
choses à partir la ctm mais mais mais
aussi à la réalité d'aujourd'hui avec
l'autre candidat de cette manne qui a un
profil un peu différent
c'est une élection uninominale pas une
élection de liste ce n'est pas une
élection sur toute la martinique
il n'ya pas programme à proposer voyez
il y a des spécificités liées à cette
élection législative qui qui singularise
plutôt une personne une personnalité une
intelligence une présence plutôt que la
dynamique de groupe avec quatre ou cinq
candidats issus du lamentin sur la
circonscription avait peur d'un
éparpillement d'ivoire oui c'est un
risque
c'est un risque forcément ils vont faire
des voix forcément ils vont recueillir
quelques suffrages sur leur nom mais
l'essentiel pour nous c'est de faire de
sorte que josette manin rassemblent le
maximum de la martinoire
mais l'éparpillement et peut-être
puisque qu'il nous faut appréhender
parfaitement raison la clé de la clé de
cette élection se trouve ou si
l'abstention
je ne pense pas vous savez on a des
chiffres un peu constant on sait très
bien que tu les législatives depuis plus
de 20 ans le premier tour se situe entre
30 et 35% et le deuxième tour avec 40 %
maximum
on connaît des chiffres qui sont à peu
près constant donc c'est très
probablement des chiffres de
fréquentation ou dab station que l'on
aura il faut faire avec mais il faut
essayer de mobiliser son propre
électorat
pour nous c'est le lamantin priorité
mais nous comptons aussi sur tous les
partenaires que nous avons sur
l'alliance ans imprimeur du nouvel os
françois avec une avec les mouvements
populaires franciscains et le parti
progressiste qui était plateau françois
robert nous avons une dynamique qui se
dit qui se développe autour de lieux
vanille williams et puis à trinité avec
le soutien du maire frédéric duval et
puis sur d'autres communes comme le
gourmand nous là aussi nous avons
quelques initiatives qui peuvent nous
laisser espérer de bons résultats quels
sont aujourd'hui vos points forts sur
cette circonscription
mais je viens de vous le dire le vous la
préférez vous c'est d'abord la note
d'abord elle a longtemps je vous et elle
a menti noise elle a travaillé au
lamentin a été élu du lamentin là elle a
donc une implantation très très légitime
sur le lamentin mais il y a aussi
d'autres notre commune qui vous craignez
d'être des candidats particulièrement
parents parlent non j'écris tous du plus
petit au plus grand oui je le crains
tous parce que crainte n'est pas le mot
mais je les respecte tous ils ont tous
une valeur ils ont tous la capacité à
mobiliser ils sont tous porteurs d'idées
peut être peu différente des notes donc
je les respecte tous mais il est très
clair que quand on va à une élection
comme celle là dont on doit compter sur
sa propre force de ses propres
propositions et sur sa capacité à
mobiliser
l'objectif de dépasser les 11 mille voix
dépasser les 11 mille voix
l'horizon objectif est de gagner ne
serait-ce que d'une voix c'est déjà ça
l'essentiel je vous rappelle que josette
a appris la présidence du conseil
général avec une voix de majorité et le
conseil général s'est très bien portés
pendant quatre ans et demi
l'essentiel c'est de gagner quand on
revient sans c'est de gagner pour porter
ses idées n'ont pas beau gagner une fin
en soi mais l'essentiel c'est ça
l'objectif chiffré le deuxième tour de
france 2 a rassemblé il faudrait
rassembler effectivement il faudra
rassembler c'est ça le principal
créer une dynamique de deuxième tour
pour rassembler autour de soi toutes les
voix un peu et parce que le premier tour
a aura permis d'exprimer le slogan de
jeu dépend pas de nous est malin c'est
pour une martinique forte et audacieuse
ce n'est pas un slogan peu fourre tout
qui veut tout et rien dire à la fois a
pas du tout pas du tout vous voyez bien
qu'il y a à la fois vos forces et le mot
audace et vous vous voyez que ce sont
des mots qui collent bien avec les deux
camps le tandem que forment josette
manége venus williams
l'audace de la jeunesse la percussion de
la jeunesse et puis la force tranquille
l'expérience de josette qui après trente
ans de 30 ans de vie politique derrière
elle alors bâti on vous a pas beaucoup
entendu l'occasion par exemple
horrifique présidentielle affronter
villareal a communiqué la normale que
nous entendons wendel ne reliés par la
queue sur la campagne officielle on a
l'impression que vous allez à à reculons
la campagne officielle de 2 des
législatives avant j'espère que vous
plaisantez à dix ans a en tout cas c'est
tout l'esprit de mauvais goût nous
n'allons pas au culot nous sommes sur le
terrain
nous soutenons josette manin bien
évidemment nous avons nous faisons
partie des dunes d'une alliance ampoules
marie noëlle et c'est agace les autres
quatre candidats majeurs serge letchimy
sion faute de france juste un profil sur
le nord et david finale sur le sud
je vous êtes manet à deux d'excellentes
chances de
la députée du centre atlantique et nous
la soutenons parfaitement si elle est
élue elle cessera à la majorité la
majorité présidentielle en un mot nous
verrons nous verrons à l'issue des
élections ce que vous savez qu'à l'issue
des élections législatives il y aura
beaucoup de discussions de négociations
notamment avec le président de la
république qui devra très certainement
renégocier ou peut-être d'affiner son
programme de trg nous verrons il sera
positionné david zobda je vous remercie
sinon toujours ici à l'écouté de nos
programmes la martinique première jeudi
fortement
[Musique]